monsieur le président à la fin du débat
avec françois mitterrand
avant-hier vous avez livré un petit
morceau de secret vous avez dit j'ai
changé ça veut dire quoi j'ai changé je
veux dire que sept ans à l'elysée dans
cet enfermement ça ça change un homme
est ce que ça veut dire que vous avez
trouvé les rapports avec les français
plus difficile et que vous ne pensiez
est ce que vous avez trouvé un monde
extérieur
plus dur que vous de la vie qu'est ce
que ça veut dire changer ça veut dire
changer
monsieur super faisait sûrement changé
depuis sept ans tous ceux qui nous
écoutent ont changé depuis sept ans moi
aussi peut être un peu plus
pourquoi pas les raisons que vous dites
que la présence à l'elysée non le fait
d'être ont fermé nous vous changent pas
les rapports avec les français non parce
que j'étais un élu de longue date donc
j'ai toujours eu des rapports avec les
français ce n'est pas ça qui m'a changé
je vous dirais c'est à mon avis deux
choses la première c'est les difficultés
de la tâche
c'est beaucoup plus difficile qu'on ne
croit et lorsque je vois le voyez les
candidats pendant le premier tour les
nombreux candidats je le disais ne se
rendent pas compte du tout de ce qui les
attend s'ils sont élus c'est beaucoup
plus difficile qu'on ne le croit parce
que il s'agit de conduire un peuple
libre donc où chacun son opinion on
prend ces décisions on s'exprime et vaut
pourtant conduire une action collective
c'est à dire faire face à des situations
ont réglé les problèmes et c'est très
difficile
donc cela vous change deuxième cause de
ce changement ce sont les dangers du
monde quand on vit dans ma fonction on
s'aperçoit que il après grand danger est
qu'on parle à des gens qui ne pensent
pas à ces dangers
j'ai eu une conversation à venise un peu
président carter au au mois de juin
dernier j'avais fait faire des
manoeuvres en france pour étudier ce qui
se passera a aucun conflit quelle serait
notre sort qu'est ce qui arriverait et
je l'avais dirait un certain nombre de
conclusions préoccupante
j'ai voulu savoir avec le président d
avis qu est ce que feraient les états
unis dans cette hypothèse
et je peux vous dire je le raconte en
détails plus tard je n'ai pas obtenu de
réponse rassurante à l'époque donc je
savais que nous vivions dans un état de
grand danger bien le fait que la tâche
difficile tous les jours et le fait
qu'on chante le poids du danger sur son
pays est quelque chose qui vous change
entre le premier et le deuxième tour
j'ai eu l'impression vous regardant la
télévision qui s'était passé un
changement subtil là aussi dans votre
dans votre manière d'être dans votre
visage un peu plus grande allégresse
qu'est ce qui vous a rassuré dans le
premier tour moi je n'ai pas trouvé
tellement rassurante de votre point de
vue c'est d'abord que les françaises et
les français m'ont placé en tête
il fallait voir que j'avais le handicap
c'est normal nous est-il sortant c'est
normal on n'en sait rien vous avez des
changements vous devez les sortants qui
ont tué des chutes considérables parler
des états unis par exemple il ya
quelques mois dont ils vont placer en
tête alors que tout le tir avait été
concentré sur moi par la première
campagne après une campagne tournée
valley france ainsi qu'au maintien le
président de la république et malgré
cela ils m'ont placé en tête ils vont
toujours laisser en tête donc c'était
pour moi très encourageant deuxième
chose qui m'a frappé c'est que un des
objectifs que je m'étais fixé je les ai
atteints c'est-à-dire gagner des votes
populaires et ça a été très frappant de
voir que dans les grandes zones
industrielles
vous avez vu que malgré les difficultés
économiques malgré la crise malgré le
chômage j'ai progressé par exemple je
citais dans le département du nord dont
pas de calais dans une partie des
bouches du rhône de la grande
agglomération populaire et c'était donc
le fait que les français deux bases
avaient compris malgré l'écran de la
campagne et malté les critiques contre
voit que j'avais essayé de résoudre
leurs problèmes pendant cette période et
donc ils avaient mesurer l'effort et
dans une certaine mesure les résultats
c'était très encourageant s'il y avait
donné l'impression d'avoir été mieux
compris par les par les français de base
comme vous dites que par une certaine
couche de français cadre c'est pas ça
s'appelle certaines clauses de france à
ces cas en france à la fois un jeu
politique qui est le fait d'un petit
nombre
analyse politi commentaires et puis il
ya le sentiment populaire et le
sentiment populaire a été plus favorable
à une candidature connaît telle analyse
politique et j'étais seul je souhaitais
questions personnelles qu'elle ait été
la décision la plus difficile à prendre
en sept ans
la plus difficile personnellement vous
les voyez ça a été la décision
d'intervention à kolwezi au zaïre été la
plus difficile
je vous la raconte en quelques mots dans
le débat de l'autre jour mon concurrent
en a parlé il a eu tort d'en parler
parce que je vous rappeler un certain
nombre de choses
comment ces deux noms se sont ils passés
il y avait déjà eu des événements ou dix
ans 77 on a peut-être oublié
la france était intervenue et nous
avions simplement faciliter des
transports de troupes notamment de nos
amis marocains qui étaient allés
soutenir la stabilité du seuil pas de
forces françaises
et puis arrive le mois de mai 78 1
samedi
j'étais à la campagne on loir et cher en
téléphone à l'heure du déjeuner et aux
médias il y à nouveau des incidents au
zaïre au chabal et gendarmes katangaise
sont entrées à nouveau aux isles qu'est
ce qu'on fait écoutez nous apportons
notre assistance technique normale au
zaïre des événements se sont déjà
produits ne vont pas de raison directe
d'intervenir dans qu'assistant secte et
que nous suivons avec attention la
situation
nous avions la chance d'avoir au zaïre
un très bel ambassadeur monsieur ross
qui est actuellement notre ambassadeur
en inde est un très bon attaché
militaire que c'était le colonel gras et
qui suivait les événements le mardi on
me prévient et on me dit l'aller faut se
tourner très mal dans la région de
kolwezi et la population européenne mais
beaucoup de belges mais aussi des
français commencent à être très inquiète
et les zaïrois n'arrive pas à assurer la
sécurité
le mercredi à nouveau sur le conseil
samedi une nouvelle alerte et on me dit
les exactions des violences des meurtres
commencer la population va être livrés
au pillage ou au massacre et katioucha a
déjà quatre jours et j'avais un visite
officielle du président du sénégal
monsieur senghor le square du sur la
comédie française et on est obligé dans
la fonction présidentielle de faire ce
qu'on a à faire
j'avais cette angoisse je rentre de vie
française de ce soir à minuit et on me
dit à 00h15 la situation se tend de plus
en plus et il ya des massacres
d'européens
je prends donc dans la nuit de mercredi
à jeudi
10 la décision d'envoyer notre 2e
régiment étranger de parachutistes ont
leur groupe dans la nuit dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi
le matin vous en réunion à l'elysée pour
voir la situation on apporte des cartes
de kolwezi personne ne connaissait
kolwezi on avait des grandes cartes et
on regarde s'il était possible aux
français de sauter et il fallait
nettoiement qui sont au centre de la
ville pour être tout de suite auprès des
gens qu'on massacre
car s'ils avaient sauté quelques
kilomètres bien entendu ceux qui étaient
dans la ville aimerait en profiter pour
terminer leur violence et la masse
faisons que sauter au milieu de la ville
il y avait un ancien terrain d'aviation
qui est au milieu de la ville et on a
regardé ses cartes on a dit c'est là
qu'il faut sauter personnes de ce qu'ils
y allaient n'y est jamais allé
on a transporté nos le militaire dans la
nuit du jeudi au vendredi l'américain
dans la nuit on avons tenu on avait
commencé dès le mercredi à prendre
contact avec les américains c'est à dire
le général d'aig et nos hommes sont
partis dans la nuit du mercredi au jeudi
sont arrivés dans la nuit du jeudi au
vendredi sont arrivés le vendredi matin
et pendant toute la nuit du vendredi
enfin de 5 heures du matin 8 heures du
matin j'étais au téléphone avec le big
data étrangères était monsieur deguire 1
go pour voir ce que ferait les belges
parce que comme il y avait également
d'importantes populations belge nous les
avons prévenus et ma crainte était qu'il
ya des fuites car il faut vous rendre
compte qu'une opération de parachute
dans un pays inconnu très loin qui se
fait deux jours nécessairement si par
hasard ceux qui sont à terre sont
prévenus ils tirent ce n'est pas juriste
et les tue un par un donc il fallait
qu'il est aucune fuite
finalement à 9 heures du matin on me dit
non les belges ne peuvent pas participer
à notre opération et je donnais ce
moment-là l'ordre de faire partir les
avions tout de suite et nous avions
décoller et entre le moment où il
décoller c'est à dire de les coller à
22h50 et le moment où il arrivait qu'ils
étaient aux alentours de 4 heures on a
là aucune nouvelle parce que les
liaisons radio et est interrompue pour
des raisons de sécurité moi j'étais
obligé d'avoir une vie normale
j'ai reçu monsieur blanc joue souvient
journalistes espagnols le miz affaires
étrangères du togo j'ai donné un
déjeuner pour les nouveaux élus du rpr
je pouvais parler de rien et
j'attendais qu'on passe un petit papier
en disant du français ont sauté ou pas
et pendant ce temps il y avait un débat
parlementaire lyonnais par parlementaire
le jeudi et un débat parlementaire le
vendredi et le jeudi on demandait le
gouvernement et notamment qui s'était
monsieur mitterrand ce pas de saisir
d'abord l'assemblée nationale de ses
intentions et il lisait il considère à
son devoir d'informer l'assemblée sans
délai comme il aurait dû le faire avant
toute décision et je me disais enfin
nous avons nos deux hommes qui sont en
l'air exposés à tous les dangers de
l'atterrissage on conseille ce qu'est
l'information parlera du retour n'écoute
naturellement s'il ya un débat à
l'assemblée nationale nous disons nous
que nous parachute ils ont sauté le
lendemain ils se font massacrer et le
lendemain pendant que nos hommes étaient
en l'air
enfin il ya eu un nouveau nouvel échange
à l'assemblée nationale et voilà ce qui
a été dit est précisément c'était encore
monsieur mitterrand il a dit il n'est
pas possible que la france participent à
ces opérations militaires sans que
l'assemblée nationale sache pas ne pas
rechuter s'est éteint hier s'il s'agit
simplement de sauvegarder la vie de
ressortissants français
si pour cela le meilleur moyen était
envoyé des troupes aéroportées et s'il
n'eût pas été préférable de s'adresser
aux organisations internationales
habilitées à cet effet moi j'avais eu
les coups de téléphone en disant il ya
des massacres
je prenais la décision je ne sais pas si
nous avions étaient arrivés on disait
est ce qu'il n'aurait pas été préférable
de s'adresser aux organisations
internationales habilitées
j'en ai gardé je ne cache pas depuis
cette époque une certaine amertume dans
lequel vous avez dit que vous aviez
commis des erreurs vous pouvez vous
souhaiteriez un journaliste d une bonne
une erreur psychologique comme ses deux
mains la sphère du 8 mai parce que
j'étais que j'étais anciens combattants
de 1945
j'étais sous les armes en 1945 vers
demain je ferai ma compagne toute la
journée avec mes quatre camarades de
chars qui était avec moi
8 mai 1945 et je pensais qu'il y avait
un geste symbolique affaire qui était
d'effacer les gains
et notamment les guerres entre
l'allemagne et la france et je n'ai pas
vu j'ai aperçu que pour les anciens
combattants il y avait là quelque chose
qui rompait avec un attachement et une
valeur symbolique qu'il est attaché au
contraire la commémoration de cette
journée c'était une erreur psychologique
peut-être moi j'ai l'impression que vous
avez commis d'autres l'une commise alors
technique mais ampleur problèmes
psychologiques j'ai l'impression que
vous avez continuellement essayer de
séduire vos adversaires qui n'avaient
aucune envie d'être séduit et que à ce
prix là vous avez parfois un peu négligé
aux amis et ça a joué beaucoup de noms
mais je crois que c'est exactement le
président de la république s'il veut
continuer de l'être
c'est quelqu'un qui doit rechercher
l'unité des français qui doit donc
s'occuper de ses adversaires du pôle et
séduire une expression tu passes à
l'adversaire mais il doit s'en occuper
parce qu'ils recherchent l'unité
la deuxième raison c'est que dans une
période de crise il ne fallait pas que
le tissu social de la france se déchire
et je me suis dit si nous laissons sur
le monde du travail
le monde des licenciés des entreprises
qui que nous voyons tous les jours se
produire loin de la politique
gouvernementale si nous concentrons
l'attraction élégance ceux qui nous ont
soutenu le tissu social français se
déchire et donc ce n'était pas pour
séduire je crois pas que ce soit vrai
c'était pour servir l'unité des français
et c'était pour éviter vous répète que
le tissu social de la france se déchire
et c'est pour ça que j'ai été frappée je
vous le disais tout à l'heure de voir
que les électeurs populaires l'avez
compris et que c'était dans des zones de
difficultés économiques comme le nord
comme la lorraine
s'il y avait une progression des
résultats parce que les gens avaient vu
l'effort bon on dit j'ai pas si c'est
vrai mais c'est une room la rumeur se
feront en france on dit que vous êtes
mal aimé des français où vous les aimez
mal que vous êtes allé
animal froid - venus souvent que votre
coeur n'apparaît que très rarement et
moi je voulais vous poser une question
qu'est ce que vous croyez que pensent
les français misent apparition du
chômage on a parlé qui est capital mais
pour le reste
quelles sont leurs problèmes les plus
importantes d'après vous êtes mon
problème c'est de contacter une
sensibilité trop forte et quand la mère
avoue la cacher oui bon on est obligé on
ne peut passer autrement quand vous
exercer les fonctions il faut pas
laisser votre émotivité manifester c'est
impossible et donc ses sermons problème
c'est pas du tout le problème contraire
qu'est ce que pense quelles sont leurs
préoccupations des français à l'heure
actuelle je crois la sécurité
quotidienne à la sécurité en cas de
général mais le fait de rentrer chez soi
tranquillement de prendre un moyen de
transport tranquillement d'hp a
barricadé sa maison quand on s'en va
quand une première préoccupation avant
le sentiment qu'on est en sécurité
quotidienne prenait dans une france
paisible deuxième problème dont on n'a
pas parlé dans cette campagne très
importante la santé et savoir que nous
avons un système de soins qui nous
protège et qui nous protègera contre ce
qui peut nous arriver
d'où notre influence pitallier
considérable et dernier à vous aussi le
fait que notre recherche médicale doit
être à l'avant garde et je pense à des
fléaux comme par exemple le cancer et le
fait aussi que nous devions traiter
beaucoup de problèmes par la prévention
nous devons être beaucoup très actif au
point de vue de la prévention des
maladies et des fléaux sociaux donc
frôlé la santé dont on a peu parlé et
nous avons préservé notre système de
soins libéral et notre système de
sécurité sociale qui est en équilibre à
l'heure actuelle mais vous avez raison
qu'ils restaurent et qui dit si nous
continuons à la politique actuelle peut
vous dire oui nous avons eu de très bons
ministre de la santé dit et je suis
convaincu que nous garderons en équipe
et une troisième préoccupation c'est
l'éducation de ses enfants
c'est à dire le fait que l'éducation des
enfants ne soient pas livrés d'abord aux
influences de la politique ou deux
des théories de toutes sortes qui est
lésé car tout de leur propre formation
je crois que le refus de la politique et
l'idéologie à l'école toute
préoccupation fondamentale des français
je souhaite que nous revenions à l'école
républicaine qu'avaient ses
caractéristiques
et puis si cette idée que l'éducation
doit fournir un métier à ses enfants qui
s'est pas seulement de savoir s'ils ont
passé quelques examens mais s'ils sont
armés dans la vie donc voilà à mon avis
les trois préoccupations fondamentales
c'est la sécurité de la vie quotidienne
la sécurité ça ne pas se retourner dans
la rue pour se voir tourner suivi ou
menacer le soir c'est la santé vivre
dans un pays qui organise bien son
système de soins de santé et c'est le
fait que ces enfants ces français se
plus beaucoup de leurs enfants chacun
chacun de nous est une éducation et un
métier un vrai métier qui les qualifie
dans la vie à venir j'ai employé un mot
qui n'est totalement rétro croyez pas
que ce qui fait souffrir et feront
cesser leur monde idéal c'est le fait
que ce pays n'a plus le rêve le champ
volutes où que ce soit vrai cette cité
des rêves c'est parce que nous avons
connu les grands événements tels que les
guerres où il y avait un élan collectif
n'auront connu ensemble c'est peut-être
la dernière génération à l'avoir connue
alors là il ya un élan collectif ou dans
le passé nous avions de grandes
révolutions affaires et ou de croiser à
les conduire dans mon actuellement pas
ses actions à faire mais je crois au
contraire que la jeunesse française gelé
senti n'est ce pas aspyr un sens de la
vie pour la france et je vais expliquer
l'autre jour en quelques mots c'est
qu'elle souhaite que la france soit un
pays de pointe
elle souhaite que la société française
soit une société fraternelle et qui
protège dans la qualité de la vie et
puis elle souhaite que nous soyons un
pays généreux présent dans le monde
tout ça c'est un très grande cité à vous
allez parler du déclin alors les
français ne crois pas du tout que le
fait d'élire monsieur ni franc
entraînera la france au déclin il pense
que vous avez bien capitalisée quel
argent avec sk près tout finalement ça
n'a pas si mal qu'ils peuvent peut-être
changer de
deux conducteurs et se débrouiller avec
mais le déclin commence à arriver à une
nation d'après regarder autour de nous
le déclin est à nos portes
le déclin ça consiste d'abord à vivre au
jour le jour à ne plus vivre qu'au jour
le jour est-ce que j'ai trouvée
franchement pas homme de mon débat notre
joie que monsieur mitterrand c'est qu'au
fond il propose à la france de vivre au
jour le haut disons au mois le mois par
on ne sait pas ce qu'on frange bien
c'est parce que donneront les élections
ont cependant su se confrontent juillet
on ne sait pas ce qu'on fera à la
rentrée
vivre au jour le jour premier signe du
déclin de diamants ne pas avoir de
grands projets on règle les problèmes
l'acculent comme ils se présentent et
dès qu'il ya une grande intention par
exemple notre indépendance énergétique
que ce que j'ai fait avec le
gouvernement ont l'art est né dans les
projets on le rend plutôt pas de grands
projets et la troisième chose c'est de
pouvoir de force et c'est symbolique
vous savez pour les historiens de penser
que mon concurrent qui sera le chef des
armées
si les prix dans la république n'aura
pas voté un centime des crédits
militaires depuis le début de la vème
république
donc ce sera à vivre au jour le jour
sans projet et sans force c'est le
déclin et vous rappelle que dès qu'un il
est à nos portes nous pouvons en voir
des exemples
dernière question vous êtes à deux jours
de l'élection et je voudrais bien être
dans votre tête pour savoir ce que vous
pensez
nous sommes à deux jours d'élections
mais qu'il ne faut pas croire que
l'élection c'est le sort personnel du
président de la république
il ya là une espèce de dédoublement qui
est faux le sort des candidats rebond
bcen sort des candidats il ya beaucoup
d'autres français qui ont des problèmes
plus difficile ou plus angoissant que
nous prenons en individuel je paye tout
ça pour moi et vous ne restez pas dans
l'esprit c'est dans le coeur et ça
rejoint votre question de tout à l'heure
c'est un sentiment d'angoissé pour la
france parce que j'appartiens à une
génération qui a vu des malheurs de la
france
moi quand j'étais j'étais enfant on a vu
les années et 38 39 on n'a vu venir là
on a vu venir la défaite
ensuite grâce aux halles de gaulle n'a
pu se redresser mais nous avons vu le
dire la défaite moi j'ai vécu dans un
paris occupé les avec le matin les
troupes qui passait sous les fenêtres en
chantant deserves étrangers s'est vu
tout ça puis vu la quatrième république
j'ai vu notre incapacité à traiter les
problèmes de la décolonisation et puis
le retour du général de gaulle et donc
j'ai vu effectivement si vous voulez que
la france pouvait connaître des
situations très très difficile et très
humide
et que à l'heure actuelle n'est ce pas
elle est capable au contraire peut-être
un des pays les plus solides d'europe on
me disait hier propos de la réunion des
ministres de l'alliance atlantique celui
qui se tait ses jours si on dit ah vous
ne vous rendez pas compte que toute
l'europe regarde le vote des français et
que la question de savoir si la france
va rester un pays solide s'intéresse à
france s'intéresse toute l'europe
à ma question est mon angoisse est la
suivante est-ce que les français vont
lâcher prise
est-ce que la main va lâcher prise c'est
ça la véritable question est ce n'est
pas une question pour moi parce que dans
notre histoire nous avons souvent lâché
prise on était près du résultat on a
l'impression que la france allait
pouvoir vivre qu'elle serait forte que
serait importante qu'elle serait
considérée même qu'elle serait heureuse
puis tout à coup parce que et une
lassitude parce qu'une harry
l'irritation même parce qu'une déception
même justifier vous me parlez de telle
ou telle erreur mot concernant on voit
la main qui lâchent prise et c'est ça
mon angoisse
c'est pourquoi d'ici pendant ces deux
jours s'ils voulaient ma préoccupation
n'est pas le bon esprit et dans mon
coeur et je vous dirai c'est en réalité
une angoisse pour la france mais
j'espère que la sagesse la solidité et
le chant ce que l'amour que les français
pour la france leur feront faire
dimanche le bon choix pour en france
merci monsieur pas dire